destiny to one of the most anticipated
and highly rated games is about to
become free to play but no one seems to
care so why is destiny do such a letdown
[Music]
welcome to Haris all B's
the first problem was that a lot of
people felt that you only got half the
content when you bought destiny 2 there
has always been a lot of controversy
about DLCs and if a game creature should
keep content away from gamers and then
demand an extra fee but a lot of destiny
2 players say it's not just extra
content but ashley half the game i
wouldn't say they are entirely wrong as
you have to buy the DLC to actually
finish the main game on top of this you
can't reach many locations where you can
farm gears and materials
you can't even access many events that
require the DLC and from the events you
can only get engrams not actual items
and this is very frustrating for many
destiny to players and when you're
looking at the price of the full game
it's a lot higher than any single retail
game originally you had to pay 40 to 50
dollars for the base game and 40 more
dollars for the DLC - until the last 80
to 90 dollars evidently prices have come
down significantly since launch due to
the uproar in the gaming community even
now many players are very annoyed that
you had to pay for things that were free
in the original game now I think
everyone understands that game companies
are businesses and that they are trying
to make money players aren't asking for
a free game like fortnight they simply
want a game that only has a one-time fee
at the beginning of 40 to 60 dollars
they don't want to make micro purchases
within the game to unlock things that
were previously free and the thing is
destiny - vanilla has a lot less to
offer when compared to the original
destiny players came off of getting over
1,000 hours of playtime from the
original destiny and here after 200
hours they would pretty much be done
with the entire game players
expectations were very high after the
original destiny and destiny - simply
could not fulfill them and the next
problem was at the game
wasn't that engaging it's not
necessarily that the story was bad but
that it was very untrue and cliche it
wasn't very meaningful and doesn't leave
a lasting impression the only
significant thing that even takes place
is that you lose a character that no one
really cared about in the first place
and at the end you end up right back to
where you started
it is also heavily scrutinized for
having shallow characters forgettable
narratives and tedious mission
structures critics do agree that there
are some good portions but they also
agreed that the vast majority of the
game like 95% plus is pretty bad
the one saving grace for destiny to
storyline is that it is a lot better
than the original destiny storyline
asked for the original destiny
critics say a dad doesn't even have a
story in the first place but just
because destiny to storyline is barren
the original destiny doesn't make it
good and destiny to really struggles to
build upon the interesting premise the
AI set for itself as for the mission
structures they're not too difficult and
the ending is dramatically anticlimactic
you assembled three Guardian leaders who
help me smuggle yourself into a giant
space laser and then when you get there
you take out a goal return to earth and
you live happily ever after okay
honestly it's not that bad but there
could have been so much more and that's
what destiny fans are looking for maybe
other guardians could get their own
light back maybe you could assemble your
own militia or at the very least you
could at least be forced to work harder
to actually steal weapons and gather
supplies but unfortunately none of this
was actually there and this all led to a
pretty stale single-player campaign you
don't just get RPG games for the
single-player experience
there's also pretty good multiplayer
experience so how is that well the
online experience was also pretty
disappointing due to another whole slew
of issues certain weapons were often
overpowered and matches were unbalanced
you usually knew right off the bat if
you were going to win or lose and this
really took out the spirit of winning
and trying and this made the matches
incredibly boring as there was no chance
for the underdog to win you always won
by a landslide
or lost by a landslide it was never
really that close
and you have to use the meta weapons or
else you really have no chance and it's
not just the game play house flawed
there's also several internal issues as
well server latency not lag is
notoriously bad with the destiny - and
this is why it often seems like a puns
are shooting you through walls and there
have been several complaints about melee
hit registration apparently mainly
sometimes you glitches through the enemy
and doesn't even register on top of this
online gameplay is heavily limited by
Bungie you can even choose what game
mode you wanna play supremacy or control
and most people agree that destiny a two
maps seem kind of small in the end the
online experience is not much better
than the single-player experience what
destiny - Bungie really ignored the core
gamer and went after casual gamers and
tried to make destiny - an eSports game
and there's a fundamental problem to
this you can't have a game as an RPG and
also a nice for shooter at the same time
there's simply a lot of differences
between shooters and RPGs and as a
result Bungie Ruby loved the RPG
features from the game they stripped and
scales down skill trees mashed power
differences between different weapons
and toned down the in-game perk system
all of this makes it game much easier
and much more appealing to casual RPG
gamers but this is not their core
audience and made them lose a lot of
their main fans the problem is that the
community for Desna - it's more of a
player versus environment RPG community
it is not a player versus player shooter
game and this chain was not welcomed by
most people who bought destiny - the
game was extremely unrewarding if you
played it as a loop based RPG and
considering that most people who played
a game play as a loop based RPG this did
not make the main audience very happy at
all
and if you haven't noticed already the
main reason that deaths need to failed
was not because there was a bad game but
because it was a bad destiny game as a
standalone game it could actually be
pretty good as appeals to a vast amount
of people but the thing is most of
Destiny's audience is previous destiny
players and as a result this was
very disappointing for them to sum up in
one sentence destiny 2 is a decent game
it's just not the game that destiny
betters are looking for or wanted to
play as a community and this underlying
issue is what led to all those other
complaints like having to pay for the
other half of Destiny 2 if destiny 2
offered an experienced I was much more
similar to the original destiny this
problem would not be as big of a
complaint and trivial issues like server
latency and boring single-player map
wouldn't even surface instead players to
be praising the much superior storyline
and overlooked the smaller maps they
would have accepted destiny too as not
the best but as a great sequel improving
upon destiny 1 the problem was that
destiny 2 was more of a different game
based on the same characters than a
sequel off of the original destiny and
this is what left many players unhappy
and many of them couldn't pinpoint this
as the issue and it went along listing
all of these other issues which really
wasn't the core problem but this is the
real reason that players didn't
reciprocate well with destiny - so what
about the future of destiny - can
destiny to make a comeback especially
when it is offered for free wait so what
is even happening with this free thing
in the first place well when the major
expansion pack lands on September 17th
the core game will become free it's
called destiny - new light and includes
all air one content including
foundational modes rewards and
activities clearly bungees planets to
luring casual gamers and get them hooked
onto destiny but will this work
unfortunately I don't think so
they've already offered destiny - for
free for a limited time last year on PC
and that really didn't lose the interest
in the game now granted PC gamers tend
to be more serious and as a result they
probably got bested - already if they
wanted it so well introducing this game
to casual gamers on ps4 and Xbox one who
mainly play games like 2k and FIFA be
effective this definitely could renew
interest but I don't think that these
casual gamers will stick around for that
long they might try it out and generate
some revenue for Bungie but I don't
really think they can bill us all
fanbase off of these people and the
thing is it's almost been two years
since a game came on and as a result
everyone who is truly interested in the
game probably already got it especially
with the recent price drops so I really
don't think that offering it for free is
really going to expand its reach I think
it's already past the point of trying to
revive destiny - destiny - is simply
dead but that doesn't mean that the
destiny community is dead there's two
out there and strong I really believe
that instead of trying to promote
destiny to the casual gamers bungie
should really focus on developing and
destiny three that really tends to core
gamers they should really focus on
catering to what their main audience is
looking for instead of trying to attract
the masses and this is what I think can
really save the series not offering a
game for free and going after casual
gamers once again destiny was a game
that many fans really adored and as a
result destiny - wasn't very highly
anticipated and based on outstanding
early reviews fans had really high
expectations but while destiny - may
have been a good game and maybe even
better than the original destiny it had
nothing that destiny fans were looking
for and it seemed like they were chasing
after a completely different demographic
that failed to materialize and this was
the main reason for their downfall now
they're trying to offer the game for
free but most of the hype surrounding
destiny - has already died down
and I really don't think that isn't
going to give a bunch of the results
that they were looking for with destiny
- hopefully eventually bunch you will
realize where they went wrong with
destiny - and offered destiny 3 that
fans simply cannot resist but till then
we can only wait but that's all I have
for you guys on white destiny - failed
make sure comment down below what you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys liked this video to mention drop a
like and consider subscribe you guys see
more videos just like this one but for
then I'm worried I'll see you guys on
the next one